if you're unfamiliar with animal
crossing or haven't played it in a while
it can be a bit overwhelming fortunately
we have some tips that should help you
get through the first few days and weeks
number one how to get nook miles quickly
as you play New Horizons you'll complete
challenges that will net you some nuk
miles these nook miles can be exchanged
for items at the Nook stop machine and
resident services there are a ton of
easy ways to earn enough miles early on
but if you're struggling we recommend
fishing bug catching picking weeds
selling seashells and chatting with your
villagers keep checking your nook miles
app to see which challenges are within
your grasp once you've paid off your
first loan you'll also unlock nook miles
plus these are infinite rotating nook
miles challenges that you can grind as
much as you want most of these
challenges are pretty easy as well
number two how to increase your pocket
space by now you may have noticed that
you can't carry a lot at the start of
Animal Crossing new horizons if you're
not because you can easily upgrade your
pocket space by redeeming pocket
expansions at the Nook stop machine it
costs 5,000 of miles for the first
upgrade which is available on day one
and 8,000 for the second you can
purchase it after the residential
services building is complete that will
take at least a few days if not a week
so be patient
number three better tools if your flimsy
tools are breaking too much it's
probably time to start crafting better
ones to do that you need to purchase
improve tools from the Nook stop machine
this will allow you to craft standard
versions of each tools aside from the
shovel which you can get from blathers
keep in mind that most of these recipes
require iron nuggets so be sure to hit
rocks each and every day number four how
to store your furniture one of the many
benefits of home ownership and Animal
Crossing new horizons is that your house
comes with a ton of storage when you are
rummaging through your pockets you can
select an item and move it to storage
you can check your storage by pressing
right on the d-pad while you're in your
house your storage expands with each
house upgrade so if you're running out
of space it might be time to pay off
your next loan number five how to
upgrade your buildings your island is
pretty bare at the beginning so you
might be wondering when you get
essential buildings like the able
sisters and nook's cranny the short
answer is just to wait it took me about
a week to get residential services and
two weeks to get the able sisters the
best advice we have without time
skipping of course
to help Tom Nook as soon as you can when
he has an errand for you and take it day
by day
number six bridges and slopes if you're
tired of constantly switching to your
ladder or vaulting pole you might be
wondering when you can start building
bridges and slopes Tom Nook will help
you build your first bridge after the
first few days however you won't be able
to start building slopes and bridges
whenever you like until the residential
services building is complete when
you've unlocked it you can talk to Tom
Nook about infrastructure and he'll help
you set up a bridge or a slope fund
number 7 visitors as you play Animal
Crossing you may spot visitors from time
to time these are special characters
like kicks and CJ that show up for the
day and can offer you some exciting
things for example if Gulliver washes up
on your Shores keep talking to him until
he gets up he'll then ask you to find
communicator parts so he can contact a
rescue party comb the beach and look for
water sprays in the sand to dig up if
you find all the communicator pieces
he'll send you a gift in the mail the
following day number eight send letters
this may seem like a waste of time but
sending letters actually has a few
benefits first sending letters to your
neighbors can earn you some milk miles
second if you attach a gift to a letter
there's a good chance the response
letter will also contain a gift this is
a good way to get more furniture
flooring and wallpaper finally when you
send letters to your villagers they will
like you more which means they will give
you more gifts throughout the day if you
found this video helpful be sure to
check out our money making guide and our
essential tips on gamespot and YouTube
thank you so much for watching
[Music]